well Lucy's fit she's fully in training
she's getting ready for the final this
Saturday
Amelia is in a good place so we're
positive he's still building but we have
some time and so she'll she'll be with
us too but we need to build a little
more but it looks good how important is
it to have those two fit fit and match
fit going into this one well of course
you want them in because they had an
important role for the team and they had
impact but you you never know what
happens in football so we think of well
the squat now who do we have what
positions can we can the players play
and what's the next step so we always
prepared with them and without them
will without Leah Williamson being in
the squad first off how disappointing is
it that she isn't there and secondly
who's going to Captain
so of course is
for her is very very disappointing and
very set but that's the same for friend
and same for bat meat and but you have
to move on too so that's that's this is
unfortunately also part of top sports
that you can get in there just a
physical game and you hope of course
that to make that risk as less as small
as possible but it can happen and
someone else steps up and this gives an
opportunity for someone else to show and
take responsibility and that's how we
approach it
hi Rob Harrison Sky News good luck for
the tournament thank you what was the
toughest decision you had to take oh
there were a couple
I don't think you can say there's one
tough decision because you're talking
about individuals you're talking about
positions but you're also talking about
combinations and balancing the team so
when you pick one player that that has
consequences for all the parts in your
in your team so that that has been
really hard but I wouldn't just pick up
one because it all have relates to each
other
his reaction when he told her that she
would be the captain and what the
quality she brings as Captain
that's how we have been all the time
we've just talked about football and we
talked she was selected and uh where
she's at right now well we have been in
contact all the time right now in uh in
her rehab and we move forward with that
so we haven't really spoken about that
yet we have a couple of weeks and um
she'll be fine she's done before